vestidos con trajes protectores blancos
la policía griega intenta convencer a
los refugiados de que se instalen en el
nuevo campo en la isla de lesbos la
agencia de la onu para los refugiados
acogió la operación con satisfacción
diciendo que unos 11.000 solicitantes de
asilo siguen durmiendo en la intemperie
mientras sea pacífico creemos que es un
buen movimiento considerando que aquí en
la calle es un riesgo para la seguridad
para la salud pública y no es la
dignidad que necesitamos para todos
el nuevo campamento tiene una capacidad
para unas 8000 personas a los recién
llegados se les está haciendo la prueba
de coronavirus con docenas de resultados
positivos hasta el momento las
autoridades griegas arrestaron a seis
jóvenes afganos en relación con el
incendio carrazo moria el mayor campo de
refugiados de europa la noche del 8 de
septiembre dejando unos 12.000
refugiados sin hogar la policía dice que
han estado usando la persuasión en vez
de la fuerza para trasladar a la gente
al nuevo campamento en un sitio no muy
lejos de donde una vez estuvo moria sin
embargo muchos son reacios a ir temiendo
que se les dejara esperando durante
meses para que sus solicitudes de asilo
sean procesadas no iré porque es como
una prisión
dicen que todos los que se mudaron al
nuevo campamento han huido de él después
de una sola noche one night 09
grecia ha pedido durante mucho tiempo
más solidaridad por parte de otros
países de la unión europea alegando que
no se debe dejar que tenga toda la carga
de la migración del continente pero
del incendio sólo alemania ha ofrecido
reubicar a un número sustancial de
refugiados